Joe Biden outright mocking Republican
talk of impeaching him over the real
bidenomics which we all know is having
Hunter scoop up millions of dollars
overseas spreading the wealth around to
his family and then pretending like he
knows nothing about it now that
inflation is coming down
maybe a little side to impeach me
because it's coming down I don't know
I love that one
oh anyway it's another story
Joe Biden can joke all he wants but the
evidence against him keeps pouring in
IRS whistleblowers have documents that
suggest the bidens have overseas bank
accounts and Congressman James Comer
revealing how sloppy they were at
covering up the foreign cash flow Banks
flagging 170 suspicious activity reports
alone but hey Hunter Biden's already
accepted responsibility so I guess we
should just leave this alone
he did attempt so far he's a private
citizen by the way to resolve this case
and has paid the back taxes Hunter Biden
has tried to accept responsibility the
Republicans in the house want to be in
an uproar they want to be apoplectic
because by God prefer Richard treatment
was accorded to the son of the president
of the United States of America why the
hell would it preferential treatment be
accorded I want to move on though to um
Donald Trump and Hunter Biden I should
not have analogized those two things
together in in my haste there's no
comparison there is today zero evidence
zero evidence that Joe Biden the
president United States knew about what
his son was doing and instead of
following the money and holding the
bidens to account Democrats in the
liberal press would rather go Hog Wild
over new charges against Donald Trump in
the classified documents case you just
feel the new sort of tightening around
Donald Trump's neck because this is all
taking place it's such an important and
dangerous moment in this case that's
probably the the final nail in the
coffin on this one I mean it reads like
a like a spy novel The Document reads
like something ripped from the pages of
The Untouchables these allegations rival
anything that Richard Nixon was accused
of this indictment reads like a mafia
case it reads like something straight
out of the gambino crime family an
extraordinary document with so many
parallels to a mafia investigation from
those 60s and 70s okay Shannon bream
please explain what we just saw
um well the you know what else reads
kind of like a spy novel is that FD 1023
form the FBI you know who didn't get to
read that the IRS agents who were
working on the hunter Biden case so
multiple things can be true there can be
legit allegations against the former
president that he's going to have to
deal with innocent until proven guilty
he's going to have to handle that in
court and have a defense to all of these
claims but that is coming against the
Optics of this 1023 form the plea deal
falling apart people feeling like wait a
minute okay those are allegations again
they've got to be proven but if you're
so outraged about all this different
conduct why aren't you equally outraged
across the board and it's got to look
like the doj is impartial in handling
both those cases the same way are you
outraged Kennedy I'm outraged you look
outraged I tell you Jesse I haven't seen
something like this uh since I watched
the end of Goodfellas you know there are
Steakhouse shootings there are bodies
and and stand up freezers uh it's just
too much no it's very interesting
because I I wonder her if the roles were
kind of reversed so if Hunter Biden were
not the president's son a sitting
president's son would he be investigated
and indicted differently would he be
charged differently and if and and I
think you know these are really the only
parallels and if Donald Trump weren't
running for president would they bother
at all with any of this and you know I
think clearly the answer is no these
things would be very different Hunter
Biden uh he wouldn't have a five-year
investigation there wouldn't be this
slow walk this run-up and I was glad it
was interesting because the judge this
week uh wasn't coming at it from a
political angle she was just asking
basic questions about how this thing
came to be and with a few of those
questions the whole thing fell apart so
quickly and I just I'm surprised that
there weren't smarter people in the room
when they were negotiating this together
to realize that the whole thing stunk to
high heaven but you know now we may have
something that seems like justice
because the whistleblowers and the plea
deal falling apart in the same week you
have to realize that there's so much
there that the rationalists in Harold's
party have to stop calling these things
you know coincidence yeah Harold what
happens when they find these offshore
bank accounts
well first of all it's good to be back
around the table I'd say a couple of
things if they find that then there's a
problem if they're if that exists not if
not that someone's concealing it
um I thought what happened in the court
and I said it the other day I thought it
was an example of how our system works
when a judge um is is presented with
parties and it's the government and and
a defendant uh the judge should ask uh
if someone's going to enter a guilty
plea for the guilty plea to be entered
in court before the court and that the
person understand the rights that he or
she's being afforded and what we learned
was that there was a complete
misunderstanding uh certainly not an
agreement or meaning of the minds
between the two parties that were
supposed to have agreed on these things
one party thought there was an agreement
about something the other the other
didn't so the thing verbally fell apart
now they have three four six weeks to
try to work out a deal I would imagine
uh that Hunter Biden's going to work
we're going to work a deal out even if
it's narrowly on these two issues uh and
what we did learn also is that he's
under investigation still that
investigation the investigation or the
investigations have not ended so Jesse
to the point you're making
um it might very well be that they they
that that those matters are continuing
to be continuing to being investigated
now I do think what happened with
President Trump yesterday is a serious
issue from the standpoint uh what CEO's
saying it's not the crime but the
cover-up and if indeed this allegation
is true uh this is a problem now I've
said all along also you are innocent in
our country until proven guilty uh
former president Trump is innocent uh
Hunter Biden is innocent and certainly
President Biden is because he's not been
charged with anything but I hope that
Politics on both sides Kennedy where I
do agree with you is that the politics
has gotten ramped up too high I mean
it's it's fine for both sides to you
know throw a little Jello here throw a
little mess here as as we get closer to
the election but at some point they
should get back to work we got a border
problem and we got a crime problem we've
got to figure out how to make the nation
more competitive so I'd love to see
those things addressed as well but this
politics around these legal issues
unfortunately I think are going to
pursue well you can do both you can you
can do that and you can also investigate
the Biden family the Dems that's the
only work they do that's the only that
when I was listening to that Montage I
felt 2015 all over again they actually
used the same phrase mafioso right that
was exactly hasn't CNN learned what that
did to their brand I mean they're barely
conscious right now as a as a as a
network and this is amazing timing
timing as the as the uh Hunter's plea
deal falls apart that suddenly these new
charges on Trump just happened to arrive
and then what about surveillance cameras
what's wrong with that what's wrong with
like are those yours why can't you
please why can't you clear them I don't
understand that they're not like other
people's emails that you then you know
disappear but I'll leave that for
another time because I'm not a lawyer
I'm more like a game show host and you
know what that means all right
yeah what about it
it goes on for an hour it's time for
what's worse with Greg Gutfeld where I
employ what about ISM to solve our
nation's debates number one what's worse
having a phone call inquiring about
influence peddling with barisma or
actually participating in the influence
pedaling with barisma yes pretty easy
what's worse licensing your name for a
university or creating over 20 shell
companies to hide foreign income that's
pretty easy what's worse calling kovid
the China virus or funneling millions of
dollars from that dictatorship into the
pockets of your family what's worse
selling steaks with your name on it or
artwork for millions in exchange for
Plum assignments on prestigious
commissions what's worse a president
going after the press or a president
going after the people
what's worse saying Mexico isn't sending
their best or blaming American agents
for whipping illegals what's worse
keeping illegal kids separate from
adults or talking about your six
grandchildren when you have
seven
finally what's worse promoting taco
bowls or losing all our baby formula
I just walked you through the last three
years to show you that whatever they
accused
doing the bidens have been doing worse
for years and they know reasonably and
arrogantly that they can get away with
it because everybody turns their heads I
thought you were going to say what's
worse promoting taco bowls or calling
Hispanics tacos oh that's a better one
but that was a great
breakfast tacos you're gonna have to
Workshop that again they'll fix it in
post it's live we're live now
ahead hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else